[Aplausos]
Mónica Ojeda es autor ecuatoriana de las
novelas la desfiguración Silva nefando y
mandíbula así como de algunos poemarios
y algunos cuentos precisamente su último
libro que fue editado en el 2021 las
voladoras es una recopilación de cuentos
que han sido calificados desde lo gótico
hasta el género del terror sin embargo
no siempre su autora está de acuerdo o
con ser tan literales en este tema Lo
importante es que Mónica Ojeda se ha
convertido en un referente
latinoamericano para la literatura y
Porque además pasa por lo fantástico
para hablar con enfoque hacia las
mujeres las historias de las mujeres y
además desde puntos que a veces son muy
violentos pero también muy humanos
precisamente ahí y Mónica Un saludo para
usted Gracias por estar con nosotros
gracias por invitarme ahí es que nacen
personajes como las voladoras que le dan
el título al libro hablemos para empezar
de estas figuras sobrenaturales de un
solo ojo con alas y bueno que atraen
todo tipo de en la humanidad Sí a mí me
atrajo mucho Bueno siempre me ha traído
las narraciones orales de Ecuador
específicamente las de la zona andina y
hay un pueblo en Ecuador que se llama
mira en donde está la leyenda de las
voladoras que es pues se dice que las
mujeres por la noche Cualquiera podría
en cualquier momento convertirse en una
voladora porque entran una especie de
trance nocturno que las hace subir a los
tejados de sus casas abrir los brazos y
salir volando lo curioso de esta leyenda
es que no es que la voladora es un
monstruo que existe y de repente Encarna
en una mujer es que cualquier mujer
tiene una voladora dentro entonces
podría convertirse en esta especie de
ser Volador en esa especie de bruja
solamente con entrar en la noche
entonces Eso me parece algo como muy
interesante porque siempre me pareció
interesante porque habla un poco de la
experiencia de las mujeres digamos en
las narrativas tradicionales no esa idea
de que una mujer que despierta por la
noche es una mujer que conoce su deseo
si conoce su deseo eso significa que es
una mujer que está como entre los
límites de lo que se le permite hacer
dentro de una determinada sociedad
conservadora por lo tanto está navegando
entre La pesadilla y la violencia entre
el deseo y el miedo etcétera etcétera no
Entonces a partir de esa historia empecé
a pensar en todos los relatos andinos
que trabajan con las figuras femeninas y
De qué manera hablan sobre cosas muy
contemporáneas que tienen que ver
justamente con esto con el deseo con la
violencia el terror todo eso atravesado
en cuerpos de mujeres bueno Esto me deja
un poco confundida porque yo tenía mi
propia teoría sobre el cuento de las
voladoras que es el primero el que abre
este libro con el mismo título y ahora
ya no sé qué pensar está bien no tiene
que pensar lo que sea cuando le da No
claro cada libro le habla de una manera
diferente a los lectores pero sí sí es
muy importante y muy interesante para
electores como yo ver este género que
han llamado gótico andino que es a de
las realidades culturales a nosotros a
América Latina y que se vuelve algo
completamente sobrenatural las Buenas
historias Mónica deben remover deben
incomodar y utilizo esta palabra porque
viendo referentes y escuchando
referentes sobre su literatura y sobre
personas que la han leído decían es que
incomoda es que uno como que no sabe qué
siente después de que termina de leer
una historia y eso es algo tan bueno
porque porque le remueve la conciencia a
uno en algún lado y eso tiene mucho que
ver con que las mujeres y las violencias
que sufren las mujeres sean
protagonistas o Usted qué opina si yo sé
que no escribo con la intención de
incomodar pero sé que incómodo pero es
algo como sorprendente cuando yo empecé
a escribir no iba con la idea de voy a
generar perturbación en la gente y claro
que no lo digo como algo malo no sino
como algo
considero algo positivo de hecho
solamente que es que incluso siendo
positivo porque lo considero positivo Es
verdad que no tenías intención Cuando
empecé a escribir es decir empiezo a
escribir sobre estos temas porque me
parecen naturales que esos temas
aparezcan en la escritura de una persona
como yo que en este caso pues estoy
atravesada por determinadas cosas Pues
soy mujer soy latinoamericana soy
mestiza pertenezco al sur global
etcétera etcétera no de un país andino
como Ecuador etcétera etcétera entonces
obviamente me atraviesa la geografía me
atraviesa la raza me atraviesa mi género
mi sexo mi identificación y orientación
sexual todo eso me atraviesa y la
escritura es siempre cuerpo o sea esta
idea Como de dicotomía que siempre nos
han vendido tradicionalmente la mente
por un lado del cuerpo por el otro para
mí no existe y creo que la escritura de
las autoras que más me interesa
justamente lo que hacen es demostrar de
qué manera la escritura es puro cuerpo o
sea las palabras salen de un cuerpo
emocionado de un cuerpo en donde las
ideas son emocionantes y son emotivas la
sensibilidad es una forma de pensar
Entonces de esa manera Uno termina
escribiendo cosas que tienen que ver con
las emociones más turbadoras del cuerpo
son las que más nos remueven como tú lo
decías Pero no hablamos de ellas y aquí
hay algo bien interesante y es que las
mujeres son a toda luz las grandes
protagonistas las grandes narradoras de
sus cuentos y yo quiero preguntarle por
qué ese interesado tanto por contar las
historias de las mujeres porque por un
lado son historias que están
normalizadas son historias que en
general son violentas pero son historias
que estas mujeres asumen digamos con
mucho valor con mucha tranquilidad con
mucha conciencia de lo que son Y a
partir de ahí pues nos dejan una
enseñanza y esa esa cierta incomodidad
que nos hace pensar o más bien
repensarnos pues como estamos viviendo
en el mundo las mujeres no totalmente yo
creo que digamos desde la mirada
patriarcal y tradicional siempre se han
escrito por supuesto las violencias
generales que experimentamos como seres
humanos pero siempre desde una especie
de exotismo cuando se escribían las
violencias que eran particularmente
de la experiencia de mujeres no como
desde ese lugar exótico y por lo tanto
sorprendente no pero claro cuando una
mujer se sienta escribir sobre
violencias que atraviesan a mujeres uno
no lo hace desde el exotismo porque es
su día a día entonces la escritura
cambia es una una perspectiva distinta
no entonces también eso también es algo
interesante no como tradicionalmente de
la escritura que siempre había venido la
canónica siempre había venido de
determinados autores además no solamente
hombres sino también mestizos blancos
etcétera etcétera
es todo eso siempre nos da una
perspectiva de lo que es ser un ser
humano no y ahora me parece que es algo
muy interesante que estamos leyendo
otras perspectivas posibles y existentes
en el mundo con respecto a esto no y las
auto yo por ejemplo escribo y las
protagonistas de mis cuentos son mujeres
pero no lo decidí Así es que me pareció
o sea como fue algo orgánico empecé a
escribir y las protagonistas eran
mujeres quizás probablemente porque ese
es mi perspectiva escribo desde este
lugar y y desde esta experiencia y desde
este cuerpo y me interesan las
violencias que nos atraviesan a nosotras
me interesa Cómo es que reaccionamos a
ellas que no reaccionamos con siempre
desde un lugar de espanto y de
distanciamiento a veces aprendemos a
vivir en el horror porque es la manera
de subsistir Y entonces esa manera
también me parece interesante no las
tácticas de supervivencia que tenemos
que van desde hacerse el muerto hasta
llevar la vida hablemos un poco del
contenido del libro entonces ahí cuentos
como la cabeza voladora
Uy uno que me llama muchísimo la
atención es sangre coagulada está el
propio de las voladoras está
mandíbula caninos caninos caninos claro
cuando es el nombre del libro y cada uno
tiene un foco muy específico sangre
coagulada por ejemplo es una historia de
aborto no es una historia de lo que
atraviesa una mujer y muchas mujeres en
el aborto de lo que hacen durante esta
práctica y sobre las huellas de abandono
que existen en las mujeres no entonces
en total hablemos un poco sobre ese tema
Porque además yo soy Mónica que usted
apoya mucho los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos y la lucha feminista por
supuesto absolutamente a mí me pareció
interesante escribir un cuento en donde
apareciera una niña hablando de su
obsesión con la sangre porque sabía que
iba a rozar con el con el género del
terror inmediatamente es decir la gente
empieza a leer un texto en donde la voz
que le cuenta la historia es una niña y
le habla de una obsesión por la sangre y
automáticamente piensa esta niña es
extraña
Este cuento Va a ser de terror y sin
embargo lo que a mí me interesaba era
avanzar en el cuento y que se fuera se
fue se fuera haciendo cada vez más
visible Cómo en realidad esto es una
cosa del día a día para una niña
adolescente que está entrando en la
adolescencia es decir las mujeres
conocemos la sangre y no la vemos Desde
esa perspectiva tan distante que a veces
la ven los escritores hombres no es así
la conocemos desde distintas maneras la
conocemos desde el embarazo pero también
la menstruación Pero hay como una
relación con la sangre distinta Entonces
en ese cuento sí que me interesaba cómo
se iba a ir pasando poco a poco en la
atención narrativa de ese extrañamiento
con la sangre a la familiaridad con la
sangre incluso hasta una relación tierna
y bella con la sangre no una relación de
repulsión ni de terror ni de miedo a la
muerte sino de familiaridad Bueno yo lo
que diría es que si hay mucha potencia
en muchas de las declaraciones que se
hacen ahí se habla de feminicidio en
algunos de los cuentos Yo pienso que se
habla de abuso en alguno de los cuentos
y esto es algo que es importante poner
sobre la mesa ahora Mónica que está
escribiendo ahora que nos puede contar
Ay ahora estoy escribiendo una novela
y está ubicada también En Los Andes
Ecuatorianos y puedo decir que que
trabaja mucho el tema de la violencia
que ahora mismo se está viendo en
Ecuador y también trabaja mucho Sobre la
música como un espacio de salvación
como me parece que es el arte en general
creo que la violencia yo escribo sobre
cosas hostiles porque el mundo me parece
bastante hostil pero también escribo
porque me parece que la escritura es
bella y la única manera que yo creo que
tenemos las personas que nos dedicamos
al arte de combatir la hostilidad es
haciendo belleza y la hacemos a través
de música de pintura o de escritura y
Porque la belleza también existe es un
mundo hostil pero también existe la
belleza Incluso en la violencia y me
llama la atención que claro usted ha
sido muy enfática en que sí a veces se
puede interpretar como terror una de sus
historias pero no significa que estén
enmarcadas necesariamente en el género
del terror y y lo que me interesa aquí
es que esas historias que nos parecen de
terror no son de terror son la vida
cotidiana de las mujeres es que es
justamente Eso me parece que a veces
mis textos en general sí que es verdad
que trabajan con la experiencia del
miedo pero no es cierto que siempre
recurren a la estructura de un cuento de
terror o de una novela de terror clásica
son dos cosas distintas
la gente que ha leído mis textos siempre
me ha dicho he tenido mucho miedo
leyéndote y sin embargo cuando analizas
los textos no tienen esa estructura no
tienen esa estructura clásica del terror
pero si tienen una estructura moderno
contemporáneo y ese terror es el
entender que el miedo no viene
necesariamente de una experiencia
fantasmática o monstruosa no es
necesariamente teratológica también
tiene que ver con experiencias muy
íntimas que se viven en una casa o
experiencias de la violencia
de las relaciones interpersonales el
miedo Es algo que sentimos todos los
días y no tiene nada que ver con lo
sobrenatural De hecho no hay nada más
natural que el miedo bueno y que un
placer Muchas gracias a ti gracias a
nuestros televidentes sigan con nosotros
en France 24 y nos vemos Próximamente en
directo América